you've been asked about we and you have
talked about these
uh mythological drake songs for a while
i actually heard one today so you played
me one of the drake records today yes i
did
drake just posted your [ __ ] on his
instagram fire he posted on the story of
the page
uh i don't know but he posted it he
posted the album you did
and uh [ __ ] lebron just
right lebron just gave you some love on
twitter he said you're one of the very
few people that he gets excited when
they drop
fire fire i seen that that was dope even
for uh drake to post that [ __ ] and
stay tapped in he congratulated me on
the album i think that's dope
all the smart people i say this all the
time all the smart people
tap in early i'm saying they tapping
early
right the curators they push the culture
they tapping early have everybody else
tap in
but uh what's up with that when we when
was the drake song coming out fam
soon i mean soon baby
soon soon i can't wait to hear that
record and he's got one
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so he's a
record it's a dope record you know i
mean i got
i got like uh
like a couple more records that i want
to put out this i'ma probably end up
putting out singles i got a record with
scott storch
he produced this so oh [ __ ] shout out
steve lobel i'm saying oh yeah shout out
steve's
my boy steve but yeah man stephen maniac
that [ __ ] got that energy like
yes you do yes you do yeah oh geez he's
[ __ ] around [ __ ] around he's still
in it to run around and [ __ ] he's still
in it bro i saw him leaving your [ __ ]
last night i'm like damn steve
why do i see you everywhere and you're
like you oh g-o-g
like yeah he'd be working shots